and finally new rule three cheers for
the millennials
who've signed up by the tens of
thousands for human challenge trials
yeah volunteering to be injected
with the coronavirus in order to
expedite a vaccine
what a great way to fight that
generation's reputation
for being safety obsessed scaredy cats
same with the recent street protests
proving young people will risk going out
for an important cause
and here's another stopping us from
falling into a depression
you know restaurants are open again but
too many are still afraid to go
we need someone to lead us back to a
life not
dominated by fear and millennials
you have just the immune systems to do
it
you know the greatest generation wasn't
great before world war
ii the war made them great because they
rose to the challenge this is your
challenge
and i'm not asking you to storm the
beaches at normandy
just storm the beaches and the stores
go to the mall and buy some pants
remember pants
be a hero just by living your best
pre-coronal life because you are the
least likely to die from it
can it get you of course as so many
other things that are still
very unlikely can as well i'm looking
at you texting while driving
so wear the masks do the precautions
but live this
this is a result of a generation that
was helicopter parented
which made you crazy it's not your fault
but this is your opportunity to conquer
your big nemesis anxiety
and show the world you're not scaredy
cats
and you shouldn't be you know how many
people in japan
under 30 have died of kovid
one and he was a sumo wrestler
you know how many people of any age have
died in all of taiwan
seven in super dense hong kong
four and that is in large part
because they are simply healthier to
begin with
as young people are in general
think about the places millennials and
gen z would normally go
like clubs people who are in clubs
have incredibly strong immune systems
ever go to one of those daytime pool
parties in las vegas
it's a pool full of people at noon who
haven't slept from the night before
a bunch of rolling roided up dudes
getting
way too much sun after unprotected sex
snorting coke through a 20
bill that has germs on it the corona
virus is scared of
plus a boatload of alcohol which they're
still drinking at noon
and they're fine people always say
the young think they're invincible yeah
because they practically
are at that age you're like a bowling
ball you get thrown in the gutter and
you pop right back up
and also you let a lot of strangers put
their fingers in you
now if you're young but not healthy
i'm not talking to you you stay home
same goes if you're a millennial who
hangs out with octogenarians
you know one of those typical young
people who says i only came here to do
two things
drink beer and visit grandpa and i'm all
out of beer
okay not you either by the way the
grandpa
issue was well addressed recently by
london journalist janet daly who said
about
lockdowns all this unquantifiable
speculative social intervention is being
done in the name of that small
proportion of people who are known to be
in truth the only ones in real danger
from the virus
so as someone who just about counts
because of my
age as one of those being protected by
everybody else's sacrifices
i assume the moral right to say this
please don't
don't give up the freedoms and the
opportunities that are proper to your
stage of life for my sake
and do not go meekly into that
imprisonment
to which the government has sentenced
you
i think she's pretty right millennials
should say to the vulnerable
we love you and we'll help protect you
but this is our time
you had yours this is our time
to set up our lives make our mark in the
world get our careers going
i got people to do and things to see and
fun to have
and if this 103 year old lady from
boston can beat it
and this 103 year old from italy
and this 113 year old from spain
i'll take the odds i'm here no fear
get used to it safety
is a virtue but if it was the only one
nothing would ever get done when jfk
ran for president in 1960 his slogan was
let's get the country moving again
no one knew what it meant but he was
young and cool so we were like [ __ ] yeah
let's go to the moon let's get the
country moving again
doesn't that feel better to you than
sitting on the couch playing video games
and masturbating to incest porn
don't answer that
you